this scene was extremely unsettling the  king hacked her to make a difficult  decision to do a c-section on ammo to  try save their child what made this  scene so much worse is that at first  emma had no clue what was happening and  the king was just trying to comfort her  saying everything will be okay and in  classic game of thrones fashion they did  make this scene quite gruesome as  opposed to leaving everything up to the  imagination of everywhere and to make  the scene even worse the child didn't  even end up surviving one thing that  i've really loved about this scene is  the way they cross-cutted between the  tournament and then the c-section but  what did you guys think of this scene  i'm glad they're not shying away from  the classic game of thrones elements  which are the brutality and unsettling  moments and just stuff like this and  also if you haven't subscribed already  please do consider doing so thanks for  watching guys